près de 200 personnes pour manifester
dans les rues de luynes du jamais vu
dans ce tranquille petit village situé à
une quinzaine de kilomètres à l'ouest de
tours
objet de ce rassemblement soutenir un
jeune pépite risque dans ce vent qui
l'oppose au maire de la commune
quelqu'un qui s'installe aujourd'hui
déjà c'est pas facile
et puis je pense qu'on lui a pas
facilité la vie
le jeune homme a installé il y a deux
ans son activité sur un terrain à
quelques kilomètres du centre de la
commune
il y produit arbustes et petits fruits
qui le vend sur place c'est bien ce qui
pose aujourd'hui problème alors que son
activité commence à bien se développer
ça se passait très bien au début la
première année tant que j'avais trois
quatre clients c'était mignon comme
activité et des cons activité a commencé
à fonctionner ce qui est quand même
l'objectif d'une activité agricole
voilà ça a commencé à poser des
problèmes à mon voisin d'en face
notamment sur les voitures qui passaient
et du coup pour m'acheter des plantes
pour m'acheter des produits de produits
agricoles en fait il se trouve que ce
voisin d'en face c'est le maire en fait
ainsi mises en cause le maire de luynes
plaide la bonne foi il ne s'agit selon
lui que de défendre l'application
stricte des règlements et de la sécurité
de ses administrés
je m'aperçois aujourd'hui tout ce que
j'ai pu lui dire gentiment pour essayer
de le guider
on ne croise un pour lui dire
paisiblement en fait il a l'impression
que c'est le maire par rapport à son
intérêt effacé personnel alors je ne
fais qu'appliquer des choses qui sont
édictées bien avant qu'il arrive des
règlements qui aurait demandé pas des
règles qui sont des panneaux ont été
placés de chaque côté du chemin
interdisant l'accès au terrain du
pépiniériste
du coup impossible pour ses clients de
charge et hero award buste seule
solution proposée aujourd'hui par le
maire lusage d'un parking de quelques
places situé à 300 mètres du terrain pas
réaliste plaide le jeune paysan
rendez vous a été pris mardi prochain
par les deux hommes gageons qu'avec un
peu de bonne volonté une solution
pourrait être trouvée pour débloquer
cette situation qui empoisonne la vie du
village